c'était un entraînement plus en détente
que d'habitude pour merrill loket
le jeune baptiste de 23 ans a appris
récemment qu'il devrait participer aux
prochains jeux paralympiques à tokyo
c'est l'aboutissement de d'un
entraînement c'est à ces quatre ans de
préparation c'est du stress est long et
puis c'est le graal quoi c'est le graal
des compétitions et puis on représente
son pays à l'international c'est moi y'a
pas mieux plus jeunes le désormais
quintuple champion de france ne s'était
pas destiné au badminton
il a longtemps pratiqué le judo avec
pour idole un certain teddy riner qui me
disait là les sports de combat n'y a pas
plus dur comme entraînements et j'ai
découvert les entraînements de bad et je
suis sorti épuisé et il a ajouté à
waimes parce que je veux moi je fais du
sport pour pour le support le
surpassement
pour sa préparation merrill bénéficie du
soutien de la ville d'andrésy en plus de
la mise à disposition d'infrastructures
pour l'entraînement elle lui a accordé
une bourse exceptionnelle avec en plus
le retard de ces jeux d'une année on a
voulu vraiment donné un gros coup de
pouce pour sa préparation pour pas
qu'ils soient démoralisé toute aide est
bon à prendre
et quand s'avère d'une ville de là où on
a vécu toute notre vie ça fait encore
plus plaisir
objectif médaille à tokyo pour l'actuel
5e mondial et dans un petit coin de sa
tête plane le rêve de remporter les jeux
paralympiques de paris en 2024